PROFESSOR: All right, so where
we are in the context of the
course is on our second
lecture on punishment.
So you'll recall that before the
break we had been thinking
about what sorts of moral norms
are appropriate: What
sort of principle underlies our
specification of moral norms?
And we're now looking at those
same cluster of questions from
the opposite side.
We're looking at that cluster
of questions from the
perspective of what ought to go
on when somebody violates
those norms, either qua moral
norms or qua legal norms as
encoded in a society's
set of statutes.
And we were looking at a number
of justifications that
might be offered for the
practice of punishment.
And we talked briefly, and I'll
say a little bit more
today, about the bottom two
of these: restitution and
rehabilitation.
But we spent the bulk of the
second half of Tuesday's
lecture thinking about
backward-looking
justification, which in many
ways is analogous to the sort
of justification of moral
constraint that we see in the
deontological picture.
What I want to do now is to look
at the first of these in
some detail, and to think about
what a forward-looking
or consequentialist picture
of punishment looks like.
And to think about the ways in
which the problems that arise
for a consequentialist account
of punishment seem to echo a
number of the problems that
arise for a consequentialist
account of morality
more generally.
So just to remind you what the
characterization of punishment
that we're working with looks
like, of which the most
important clause is going to be
the first, we're making use
of the classic mid-century
characterization of punishment
that comes out of the
Anglo-American legal
philosophical tradition.
And what's key in thinking
through the justification of
punishment from a
consequentialist perspective
is to remember that punishment
is done in response to a legal
offense, is done by one judge
to the offender, and so on.
But it's also something that, as
part of what punishment is,
involves the imposition of
unpleasantness and suffering
on the person to whom
conditions two
through five apply.
And the question we're trying to
answer for ourselves is how
a state could ever be justified
in bringing
deliberate disutility to
one of its members.
So what the harm reduction or
consequentialist outlook says
is that the sole goal of, or
the sole justification for,
punishment is to prevent or
deter future wrongdoing.
Consequentialist accounts,
in their pure forms, are
interested solely
in consequences.
And to the extent that they're
concerned with the
distribution of utility across
members in a society, what
they're interested in is the
maximization of utility from
that moment onwards.
They're called future-directed
because though they may take
the past into account to the
extent that the memories of
individuals take the past into
account, they don't take the
past into account as something
relevant to the
calculation of utility.
The sole goal of punishment is
to prevent or deter future
wrongdoing.
And the sole justification for
punishment is to prevent or
deter future wrongdoing.
Now if a utilitarian account is
to serve as a justification
for punishment as a practice,
punishment being the
deliberate bringing about of
disutility to a member of the
community who has violated some
moral or legal norm, then
it must be the case, for
it to be justified on
consequentialist grounds, that
punishment is an effective,
and indeed, on some accounts,
that punishment is the most
effective mechanism for bringing
about the prevention
or deterrence of future
wrongdoing.
If there's some alternate way
of bringing about an equally
beneficial result, then it
can't be justified on
consequentialist grounds to
impose harm or suffering on an
individual.
That's what the consequentialist
picture says.
And notice, this is the mirror
image of some of the
perplexities that we found
ourselves getting into around
things like the surgeon case,
where if all one takes into
consideration are distributions
of utility, then
a lot of the factors that go
into common sense reasoning
about cases seem to fall out
with respect their relevance.
So the suggestion, if the
empirical hypothesis is
correct, is that punishment is
the most effective mechanism
for prevention or
incapacitation.
That is, it's the best way of
precluding the possibility of
wrongdoing on the part of the
perpetrator, and/or that it's
the best mechanism for deterring
wrongdoing, either
on the part of that individual
or on the part of others who--
as the result of making public
the practice of punishment--
come to recognize that what
you might think of as the
cost-benefit analysis
of performing a
particular act changes.
So Jeremy Bentham
famously says--
Jeremy Bentham was the
utilitarian predecessor of
John Stuart Mill, the person who
originally articulated in
the modern philosophical
tradition how it is that we
should think of consequentialism
--
so Jeremy Bentham famously said,
what punishment does is
to change the calculus of costs
and benefits associated
with a particular act of
wrongdoing, and to attach to
something which is generally
beneficial some sort of cost,
so that that can enter
into the calculus.
In the literature on
conditioning and
reinforcement, punishment is
something that changes the
contingencies associated
with a particular act.
It brings a penalty along with
a reward to something that
typically carries
only a reward.
Or it reduces the reward
associated with something that
generally brings
a high reward.
Now it should be clear to all
of you, because we went
through the mirror image of
this in the positive case,
that thinking merely in terms
of consequentialist
justifications for punishment
seems to carry with it two
kinds of problems. The first
problem is that the
consequentialist justification
seems to under-generate
reasons for punishment, if we
remember that punishment
involves the deliberate bringing
about of a harm.
So, for example, it may well
be, with respect to the
question of incapacitation, that
if our sole goal is to
incapacitate individuals who are
likely to commit crimes in
the future that will bring
disutility to society as a
whole, if our sole goal is to
incapacitate them, then there
may well be equally effective
non-punitive alternatives.
Remember condition one in
our characterization of
punishment.
Punishment involves
state-imposed pain or suffering.
It involves the deliberate
bringing about of disutility
to an individual.
Presumably, simple
incapacitation can be done in
a way that does not involve
anything more than the minimum
amount of imposition of
suffering on the individual.
So any amount more than required
for incapacitation
can't be justified on this
consequentialist ground.
Moreover, it seems, not just
with regard to prevention,
that there's a possibility of
non-punitive incapacitation,
but also with regard to the
question of deterrence.
Presumably, if one's real
concern is to reduce the crime
rate, then there are things
that are a good deal less
expensive than the prison system
to bring about that
desired goal.
Creating social situations in
which people have access to
education and access
to employment may--
an empirical question--
be a more effective means of
deterring crime than public
punishment.
Particularly if one of the
results of jailing
individuals, many of whom are
parents, is to leave the next
generation of children in a
position where the kind of
stable households, that we
know from our earlier
discussions of what it is that
allows people to have
well-ordered souls.
Many children growing up in
households that don't provide
them with that sort
of stability
might have social costs.
So let me reiterate, these
are empirical questions.
It is an empirical question
whether the most effective
form of incapacitation is one
that in addition involves the
imposition of more suffering
than is required for
incapacitation at the time.
Perhaps that has better
long-term consequences in
terms of preventing
future crime.
Likewise, perhaps the most
effective form of deterrence
is a kind of punishment that
brings with it a publicity
that causes others to avoid
behaviors of that kind.
But if it turns out that the
prevention requires simple
incapacitation and that
deterrence seems more
effective through some other
means, consequentialism can't
give us a justification
for punishment.
So the first problem with the
consequentialist argument, if
what you're trying to find
is a justification for
punishment, is that it
under-generates.
The second problem is that in
certain cases it seems to
over-generate punishment.
So it seems--
and we read about this in the
John Rawls piece that we read
for last class--
to license what's sometimes
called telishment.
Where telishment means focusing
on the telos,
focusing on the goal, focusing
on the end, rather than
focusing on the process.
So how might this go?
Here's an example.
Here's a community
of shepherds.
They all look like Gyges.
And there they all are
with their horses.
In comes our standard bad guy
and steals two of the horses.
The police come looking
for him.
And he leaves town.
So there's no one to punish
for stealing the horses.
Poor Jim, unlucky, shows up
just at the time that the
police have come looking
for a perpetrator.
And the police realize that a
very effective way to prevent
the stealing of future horses,
perhaps, would be to put Jim
in jail and write a big
newspaper article about it:
"Horse Thief Captured!
Sentenced to Life in Prison."
That is, the deterrence effect
that is demanded by punishment
seems, at least in principle,
as if in certain cases it could
be carried out equally
effectively by bringing
punishment, or something like
punishment, to bear on an
individual who is not in fact
the one who perpetrated
the crime.
If the goal is deterrence, and
if the hypothesis that
publicizing punishment is what
produces deterrence, then it
seems as if there aren't
resources in the conceptual
repertoire of the
consequentialists for denying
telishment.
As with the standard cases of
the surgeon cutting up the
patient, there are more
complicated moves that the
consequentialists can make.
And the suggestion is not that
it's impossible within a
consequentialist framework to
rule out something like
telishment.
The thought is just that it's
important to be clear what
resources are available to you
if this is the justification
to which you're appealing.
And to recognize, that at
least prima facie the
consequentialist justification
seems both to under-generate
and over-generate things that
look like punishment in cases
where, at least as encoded in
our inherited legal statutes,
it violates the norms to which
people feel themselves
intuitively drawn.
So how might we get around
this problem?
Remember there were problems,
it seemed, with the
retributivist picture, and
problems it seems with the
consequentialist picture.
One of the standard ways of
getting around this is to
introduce what might be called
a two-level theory.
And we read an example of one of
the most sophisticated and
influential two-level
theories in our
readings for last class.
So John Rawls, from whom we'll
hear again in a couple of
weeks, the political
philosopher, wrote in the
1950s a famous paper called "Two
Concepts of Rules." in
which, one of the things that
he analyzes is punishment.
And what he suggests is that we
think about the question of
the justification of punishment
in a more
complicated way.
That we think first about what
it is that justifies the
practice itself: What makes it
legitimate for a society to
have punishment?
And the suggestion is that what
justifies the practice
itself is that having such a
practice in place is something
of societal utility.
But that once we have set up the
practice, what justifies
particular actions within the
practice is retribution.
And he suggests, later in the
paper, that we think of this
distinction between justifying
a practice and justifying
actions within a practice, on
analogy with something like
the rules of baseball.
So when we set up the rules of
baseball, we can have a debate
about whether baseball would be
a better game if there are
three strikes or four strikes.
Whether baseball would be a
better game if stealing bases
is allowed or disallowed.
Whether baseball is a better
game if, or if not, pitchers
are also treated as batters.
So that's the debate about the
nature of the practice.
And you might think when we're
debating the nature of the
practice, one sort of
consideration comes into play.
But once we have the practice
in place, we don't have
debates in the context of a game
about whether it would be
better in that particular
instance for a batter to get
four strikes.
Or whether it would be better
in that particular instance
for a stolen base to count
or not count as a way of
advancing across the bases.
So we can distinguish between
what it is that sets up our
practice, and what it is that
happens once our practice has
been set up.
And Rawls' suggestion is that
what justifies the practice in
the case of punishment is a
general picture of utility,
whereas what justifies acts
within the practice is
something like retribution.
And the suggestion is that this
manages simultaneously to
resolve two problems. It
resolves the problem of
under-generation, in some sense,
because if the general
practice isn't useful, then the
practice will be abandoned.
And it resolves more clearly
the problem of
over-generation, the problem
of telishment, because it's
ruled out as an act within
the practice.
We've set up the rules of what
punishment involves.
Those are justified on
utilitarian grounds.
But within the practice we can't
do things like put Jim
in jail as a way of deterring,
because that's prohibited
within the practice.
So it might seem that the
pluralist challenge, or the
pluralist solution, to the
dilemma of how punishment
might be justified, either
retributively or on
consequentialist grounds, solves
the problem with which
we were concerned.
Which is, how can the state ever
be justified in bringing
about harm to its citizens?
But there are, I think, three
questions that can be raised
even with regard to
this solution.
So we might ask whether utility
alone, without appeal
to retribution, can really
serve as the sole
justification of the practice,
or whether in fact the
under-generation problem is just
going to re-emerge at the
level of justification
of the practice.
We can ask whether retribution
alone, without appeal to
utility, can serve to justify
actions within the practice,
or whether ultimately in order
to capture what it is that we
want punishment to do, even
once we've established the
practice, requires some
appeal to retribution.
And I'll talk about
the psychology
of this in a minute.
And finally we might ask
whether, given the
distinctness of the two
levels, we've provided
anything like a coherent account
of what justifies
punishment.
If one sort of reason governs
the practice, and another sort
of reason governs the
application of the practice,
then even if each of them
independently is able to do
that work, in fact, especially
if each of them independently
is able to do that work, one
might wonder how the two
together provide a
coherent account.
So that closes what I want
to say about the general
philosophical issues underlying
punishment as a practice.
We thought through two of the
standard justifications, and
then a third which attempts
to reconcile them.
And let me again remind you that
part of what we're doing
here is thinking more generally
about moral
justification.
So all of the arguments that
we've considered in the
context of punishment have
direct analogs in the positive
mirror image of it.
What I want to in the last half
of lecture is to talk
about three additional
questions.
These are the readings that
we did for today.
I want to talk about the
psychology and the
psychological constraints that
seem to constrain any picture
of punishment that we're going
to have. That's going to
accord with how it is that it
appears people intuitively
respond to particular instances
of norm violation.
I want to connect what we've
talked about in the context of
punishment with the issues that
we talked about around
luck at the end of our classes
before March break.
And finally, I want to bring us
back to some Aristotelian
themes about virtuous character
by talking about
punishment and parenting.
So there's been, in the last
thirty years or so, a vast
body of empirical research
conducted by a number of
extremely sophisticated social
psychologists who have looked
both at people's responses to
hypothetical cases and at the
legal codes of numerous
societies in an attempt to get
not at the normative question,
what should justify
punishment, but at an answer to
the descriptive question,
what psychological human need
does punishment address.
And in exploring these
questions, John Darley--
from whom we've read selections
at a number of
points in the course, including
for today--
makes appeal in his discussions
to the very
distinction that we've been
talking about with respect to
the normative question.
So you can distinguish in
looking to see what factors
affect people's decisions about
punishment, whether what
they seem to have their
attention directed to are
questions of things like just
desert and retribution.
That is questions--
does it affect how likely or
how severe their punishment
will be, if it looks like the
individual in question
intended to do a great amount of
harm, regardless of whether
he or she succeeded at it?
Does it affect people's
assessment of bringing about
of harm, if the individual, for
example, stole money to
give to a charity, as opposed
to stole money to
buy herself a Ferrari?
If questions about what
was going on in the
individual's mind--
did the individual intend to
bring about the harm or not --
if questions about what goals
the person had with respect to
the proceeds of the crime--
did they want to use them for
something prosocial or
something antisocial --
then it looks like one of the
kinds of considerations that's
coming into play when people
reason about punishment are
things about retribution.
By contrast, if when people are
thinking about what kind
of punishment to impose, what
they look at are things like,
how likely is a crime like this
one to be detected, or
how public is the act of
punishment going to be, then
it seems like the underlying
psychological mechanisms
behind punishment are ones that
are primarily sensitive
to consequentialist
constraints.
So in a series of studies over
the last several decades,
psychologists have asked the
question, to what sort of
variations are punishment
judgments sensitive?
In general, when people are
assigning punishment, when
people are assigning severity,
when people are deciding
whether to punish or not, do
they, if given the chance to
look for information, want
information, for example,
about the criminal's state of
mind or about the criminal's
motivation?
Or do they want information
about how widely publicized
the punishment is going to be
or how likely crimes of this
sort are to be detected?
And it turns out fairly
consistently that it's
considerations of the first type
that seem to be driving
people's responses.
That is, that a utility calculus
doesn't seem to be
the primary motivation when
individuals who are surveyed
in psychology studies, or penal
codes, are looked at as
indications, of the
psychological mechanisms that
underlie punishment.
And we see further evidence in
favor of this hypothesis if we
consider a phenomenon that's
sometimes known as altruistic
or costly third-party
punishment.
So these are cases where an
individual, A, punishes--
that is brings about harms
and costs to--
another individual, in a way
that, first of all, brings a
cost to A, brings no direct
benefits to A, and concerns a
norm violation that didn't
affect A in the first place.
So for example, I'm standing in
a long line waiting to get
my iPad 2, and a person cuts
in line behind me.
Right-- so, he cuts
It doesn't affect my
access to the iPad.
I might punish him by inviting
everybody that stands behind
him to cut in front
of both of us.
That makes me worse
off, right?
I've just let everybody behind
me in line cut in front of me.
It doesn't directly benefit
me in any way.
And the thing for which I
am causing a harm to the
individual behind me is not
something that concerned a
norm violation directed at me.
He cut in line behind me.
And we see instance after
instance of behaviors with
this structure in the
behavioral economics
literature.
It appears for whatever
reason.
Perhaps because this is a way of
promoting a certain kind of
evolutionarily stable
prosociality.
Perhaps because norm violations
tap into heuristics
that cause people to act
in certain ways.
Perhaps for some third reason.
It appears that in numerous,
both laboratory and public
settings, individuals engage in
punitive acts that have the
structure articulated above.
Consequentialism, at least
in its simple form,
can't explain that.
Finally, state of mind seems to
play a large role in how it
is that people respond to
situations that potentially
involve punishment.
So suppose poor Jim comes over
to my house, and hidden behind
the door is my prize umbrella.
And Jim knocks on my door, and
I say to Jim, "Come in." And
Jim walks in the door and knocks
over my prize umbrella
in a way that causes him to
stamp through it and poke a
hole in my umbrella.
And he says, "Oh no, your prize
umbrella." Case one.
Case two, Jim shows
up at my house.
And I say to him as he knocks
on the door, "Jim, Jim look
out for my umbrella as you come
in!" And Jim opens the
door and stomps on my prize
umbrella, putting a hole in
it, and says, "Oh darn, your
umbrella!" Case number three,
Jim knocks on my door.
I say to him, "Jim, look out
for my umbrella!" Jim opens
the door, stomps on my prize
umbrella, and looking down at
his footwork says, "Yeah!
I smashed your umbrella!"
What sort of responses do
these three cases evoke?
Here's our famous Bad-o-meter
that you will recall from our
various trolley and
other cases.
When Jim accidentally stomps
on my umbrella--
the first case where I said,
"come in Jim," and he stomped
on it and said, "Oh no, your
umbrella!" There's harm, but
it's treated as pretty
low-level.
When I say to Jim, "Look out,
my umbrella!" And Jim
nonetheless opens the door and
stomps on it and says, "Oh
darn, your umbrella!" he's
done something negligent.
And there's a sense, on the part
of most subjects, that
something slightly worse
has occurred in
the general bad direction.
And when Jim comes into my
house and stomps on my
umbrella and proudly looks down
at what he's done, having
done so, it seems,
intentionally, there is, on
the part of most subjects,
a sense that
something worse has happened.
Consequentialism alone
can't explain this.
In all three cases I've got my
poor stomped-on umbrella.
What can explain this is a
response that individuals seem
pretty persistently to have
across cultures, which is
sometimes called the phenomenon
of moral outrage.
In the accident case, there's
no moral outrage at all.
Nobody thinks, that was morally
outrageous of Jim to
step on my umbrella, given that
he didn't know it was
behind the door and had just
come in in response to my
request that he enter.
In the negligent case, there's
some irritation, there's some
moral outrage, there's a
feeling: "Jim, I told you my
umbrella was there." But
the moral outrage
is relatively low.
But in the case where Jim did
something that strikes us as
having been an intentional
bringing about of harm, in
direct violation of my request
that he not do so, "Jim look
out for my umbrella"
there's a response
of high moral outrage.
And what Carlsmith and Darley
suggest, in the article that
we read for today, is that these
attitudes of either no
moral outrage, low moral
outrage, or high moral outrage
direct our attention
to different
parties in the episode.
When there is an event that's
happened that doesn't produce
moral outrage at all, there is,
except with respect to a
general desire to make the
world a better place, no
attention either to the victim
or to the perpetrator.
Bad stuff happens.
We might go about trying
to change the world.
If there's an extra supply of
umbrellas in my car, I might
bring one of them in.
But in general, when things
happen by accident the
perpetrator isn't a focus
of attention.
And the victim is no more a
focus of attention than he or
she would be if this had been
brought about as the result of
a gust of wind having destroyed
the umbrella.
In cases of low moral outrage,
attention is
directed to the victim.
There's a tendency to focus on
compensation, on the need to
make things better.
But there's no focus on the
perpetrator as someone in need
of our focused punitive
attention.
But in the case--
and in a moment I'm going ask
you to take out your clickers
because we're going to talk
about intentional action.
In the case where the act that
violates the moral norm is
seen as having been intentional,
there is a
tendency to focus not merely on
compensation, but also on
punishment.
This is an extraordinarily
resilient pattern, and one
that seems very interesting
psychologically if we're
trying to come up with moral
codes that will seem to
evolved human beings, to strike
them as satisfactory.
But one problem with this
picture is that it turns out
that determining whether an
action was done intentionally
may well be more complicated
than it
had initially appeared.
So my colleague, and your fellow
Yale professor, Joshua
Knobe, has done a wonderful
series of studies on the
question of what it is that
leads people to think of an
action as having being performed
intentionally.
And we're doing the study in
the way that all of you are
going to get both vignettes.
So we won't get exactly the
distribution that's indicative
of typical responses.
But I think it's nonetheless
interesting for you to think
through the cases.
So how many of you have seen
these cases before?
Just hands.
Ok, so about 5% to 10% of you.
So Josh Knobe presents his
subjects with scenarios,
vignettes like the following.
The vice president of a company
went to the chairman
of the board and said,
"We're thinking of
starting a new program.
It will help us increase
profits, but it will also harm
the environment." The chairman
of the board answered, "I
don't care at all about harming
the environment.
I just want to make as
much profit as I can.
Let's start the new program."
They started the new program.
Sure enough, the environment
was harmed.
The question is this: in
starting that program--
"I don't care at all about
harming the environment, I
just care about making
a profit" --
is it the case that the
chairman harmed the
environment intentionally?
Did the chairman one, yes harm
the environment intentionally,
two, no, did not harm the
environment intentionally?
Huh?
People didn't really have
their clickers out.
There's only 70 of you.
OK, let's see how it came out.
So 77% of you think that he
harmed the environment
intentionally.
And we'll now try
the second case.
Second case-- try to forget that
you just had the first. I
know you can't do that, but
try to do it anyway.
The vice president of a company
went to chairman of
the board and said "We're
thinking of
starting a new program.
It'll help increase profits.
But it will also help the
environment." The chairman of
the board answered, "I don't
care at all about helping the
environment.
I just want to make as
much profit as I can.
Let's start the new program."
They started the new program.
Sure enough, the environment
was helped.
So the chairman says, "I don't
care at all about helping the
environment.
I just want to make a profit."
Question, did the chairman
help the environment
intentionally?
One, if yes.
Two, if no.
And let's see how the
numbers come out.
Wow!
You guys are amazing!
All right, you came in even
cleaner than standard Knobe
results, even though I gave
you the two cases
sequentially, which should've
mitigated the effect.
But there we go.
So classically, when you present
this to people, in the
first scenario where you guys
gave 77% yes he harmed it
intentionally, roughly 83% of
people say that he did.
Whereas, in the second case,
where you guys gave this
amazing 89% that he didn't
help the environment
intentionally, typically
this number is 23%.
So that one's 67--
sorry, 77.
OK, now what's going on here?
Let me remind you what
just happened.
We had two identical
scenarios.
The only difference is that we
changed the term "help" here
to "harm" in the first case.
In both cases, what the CEO said
is, "I don't care about
thing you think I did
intentionally in the first
case and thing you didn't think
I did intentionally in
the second.
I just care about making a
profit." So something that he
was ignoring in the first case,
most of you thought is
something he was intending
to do.
Whereas something he was
ignoring in the second case,
almost none of you thought
he was intending to do.
That's perplexing if what's
going on here is that
punishment is supposed to be
tracking intentional action.
Because it looks like what kind
of action we take to be
intentional is in some way
confounded with what sorts of
actions we take to be
morally problematic.
So that makes the whole question
of how we ought to
think about punishment even
more complicated than it
struck us already.
But let's set that aside
temporarily and think about
what implications there are from
the psychological results
that we've just been studying.
On the one hand, it looks like,
psychologically, paying
attention to backward-looking
or retributivist reasons for
punishment, to the rebalancing
of the scales of justice, is
psychologically required for a
theory to feel satisfying.
Or at the very least, that
simply looking forward and
thinking about consequentialist
considerations and utility
doesn't seem psychologically
sufficient.
So the question is whether,
taking human psychology
seriously, there's an additional
alternative.
And a number of psychologists
and philosophers have asked
the question whether if we
look not backwards and
forwards, towards the
performance of the crime as
something that demands a
rebalancing of the scales of
justice, or towards the utility
which can be brought
to society, but rather at the
things that we were calling
three and four in our initial
characterization, at
restitution and rehabilitation
as our motivations, can we
somehow get a psychologically
satisfying account of
punishment, where the goal is
not rebalancing or utility,
but rather some sort
of reparation?
This is sometimes called
restorative
or reparative justice.
And those of you who are
intrigued by it, I'm pointing
you to a location where
you can read
articles about that question.
OK, so that closes the first
part of our discussion, the
psychological implications
of punishment.
And what I want to do in the
last five minutes of lecture
is to talk about the interaction
with luck.
And then we'll begin lecture
next Tuesday by talking about
the connection in the context
of parenting.
So we've been thinking
throughout this unit about the
cases like this, where luck
seems to play a role in
consequences.
When the person didn't
intend to do harm.
Unlucky Cell Phone and
Unlucky Alert had no
desire to harm the child.
But of course, luck can play a
role in cases where somebody
is deliberately trying
to bring about harm.
So here's our standard bad
guy, who shows up in town
where there's a potential
victim for him.
And he pulls out his gun and
says, "Oh yeah, I'm gonna
shoot that guy." And luck
is on his side.
Intention carries out
in the way that he
intended and he succeeds.
His perfect analog, Unlucky
Shooter, shows up in town and
says, "Oh yeah, I'm gonna shoot
that guy." But when he
pulls the trigger,
unfortunately, just at the
moment that his bullet would
have hit his intended victim,
up comes the truck that was in
our last story, and stops the
bullet in its tracks.
So he doesn't succeed at
his intended crime.
Notice that this is the mirror
analog to the previous case.
The intention in the two
cases is the same.
The action in the two
But in the first case the
criminal has been lucky with
respect to his intended goals.
He shot the guy that
he tried to shoot.
Whereas in the second case the
criminal has been unlucky with
expected goals.
He didn't manage to
shoot his victim.
The question is why we
punish this one more
seriously than this one.
What sort of justification could
possibly underlie this?
And David Lewis in the rather
complicated, I admit, paper
that I had you read for today,
and I promise we will talk
about in sections to help you
understand what the logic of
the argument is, but David Lewis
suggests that the only
thing that could justify
treating this act as more
punishment worthy than this one,
is if we think it would
be all right to impose what
he calls a penal lottery.
So what he says is, if we knew
objectively that when you
engage in a shooting action
where you pull a trigger
there's a one in ten chance that
your action will fail and
a nine in ten chance that your
action will succeed, then
punishing you is fundamentally,
in our current
system, equivalent to having you
draw a straw from among a
set of straws where there are
nine that send you to a long
prison term and one that sends
you to a short one.
And he suggests that we can see
that our current practice
is akin to that by bringing
you through a series of
imaginary cases, each of which,
he suggests, has the
same justification as
this straw drawing.
So imagine a system where once
we've established that the
intent was equal in
the two cases.
We had our two individuals
here just draw straws.
Each of them has a one
in nine chance of
getting off the hook--
sorry a one in ten chance.
And a nine in ten chance
of getting to jail.
That corrects for luck.
Equivalent to that, says
Lewis, is not that the
individual draws the straw,
but that before the trial
takes place, a court
representative draws the straw.
And though the jury is just
deciding, "did he intend to do
it?" they don't know
in advance what the
penalty will be.
Equivalent to that, he suggests,
is that beforehand,
the court representative draws
the straw and makes public
that if they convict him of
intending to do the crime,
then he will either receive
the nine penalty, the more
severe one, or the one.
Equivalent to that, suggests
Lewis, is that beforehand we
provide a reenactment of the
crime, with similar odds, and
if the victim dies in that case,
then the individual will
get a more severe punishment.
And, suggests Lewis, our
actual practice of just
letting the world play itself
out, so that we punish the
person whose crime attempt
succeeded more severely than
the one whose crime attempt
didn't, is just a
pre-enactment, morally
equivalent to a re-enactment,
morally equivalent
to the drawing
of straws in a lottery.
So I'll close with that as a way
of trying to bring out yet
again the perplexity of moral,
or perhaps, immoral luck.
And we'll open next Tuesday with
our discussion of Kazdin
and then move on to our
selection from the writings of
Thomas Hobbes And
I'll post that
reading for you by tomorrow.
Thanks.